[Music]
some people are firm on the notion that
social media is bad for society some say
that it disconnects us more than it
connects us they point to the increases
in depression and anxiety as reasons why
it's not good for our mental health but
I want to give you one example where
social media has had a fantastic impact
on our society in the midst of my social
media Fame I started a foundation called
limitless tomorrow and my aim was to
help other individuals and even
companies who aspire to do great things
in this world to make a change that
affects all of us as humans the startup
funding for this foundation started
through a unique collaboration between
coffee meets bagel a dating app and
myself I ended up auctioning a date off
for charity and raised almost a hundred
thousand dollars for my new foundation
now a lot of people have asked me
questions where did that money go where
does it go now this video highlights a
prime example of a person set out to
change the world in a positive way for
us all
meet dr. Angelo Leto Baroni
approximately 10 million people overall
in the world suffer from various ear and
nose deformities
I reckon strata we have a dream we
imagine a world where we can easily
treat the severe facial deformities in
an easy reliable and cost-effective way
so basically thanks to limitless
tomorrow we were able to create a cookie
cutter for ear nose reconstruction dr.
Leto brownie can you tell us what your
current position is and how you figured
out that you're gonna go into your field
of choice and because we have a lot of
medical students watching they're trying
to figure out what they want to do with
their lives they they're curious to know
about all aspects of Medicine so how did
you get into the field that you're in
now absolutely so I was actually six
years old and I saw this man go around
my town back home in in Italy and he was
going around he had a complete burn of
his face it was completely disfigured
and I was looking at this person and I
saw that he had lost like a sense of
self so I just pulled my mom
I was like what who's the doctor who
does that who fixes that and she was
like you know being a physician pretty
impressive for a six-year-old right and
she was like plastic surgeon is like
that's what I want to be but you have a
unique journey because you didn't just
go and do the specialty here in the
United States you were born in Italy
right right
Palermo is your hometown yep where I
went to medical school miss and how did
you do that did you go through medical
school right away what's the training in
Italy like so the training is you do
five years of high school and then it
was very rigorous and then you go
straight into Medical School which is
six years which is different than what
we have here in the United States
because we do high school University
that medical school correct
and then in medical school were you set
and saying I'm gonna specialized in
plastics
I was said everyone kept saying you're
gonna change your mind a thousand times
didn't happen I had my mission okay and
I stuck with it and I went to at the
university of Palermo Medical School
then I was recruited to the residency
with the program there and then I
decided that no is that is that a
competitive process because here in the
United States if you want a plastic
surgery residency very difficult you
have to be at the top of your class as
you know if you're a foreign graduates
very difficult to get a position in
plastic surgery residency so how is that
in Italy is that compared is also very
challenging there is less spots and also
less people applying but at the same
time you can only apply to one program
at a time
Wow so I applied to the only program
that I was interested in and you either
match or don't match so it's a little
bit more scarier yeah okay a little
scarier I did a lot of research through
residency a few years I was at Harvard
at the Mass General and then I went back
home finished residency and decided to
come back and join the the Johns Hopkins
University of Maryland interesting so
what kind of research did you do there
while you were it was mostly tissue
engineering and vascularized composite
allotransplantation which is that's not
complicated at all but totally easy to
say it's it's a fancy word for face and
hand transplant research okay so you
know that these operations
besides being extremely
challenging they require a lot of
immunosuppressants to make sure that the
body doesn't reject the face from the
cadaver Wow very impressive stuff you're
working at Johns Hopkins you're happy
but very tired plastic surgery Rises and
you wake up one morning or you're in the
or one day and you say I have an idea
yeah do that so it was both in Italy and
the US the idea started mostly in Italy
we were doing a case and we were
basically having problems with the
cartilage and lacking cartilage and and
I was thinking as we were trying to
treat this micro shock a so this kiddo
was born without in here and we were
trying to carve this ear out of rib
cartilage which is a cartilage that
comes from the rib cage I realized that
it was a process that was that entailed
a great amount of detail and skill that
probably most Plastic Surgeons do not
have despite going severe training but
he also required a very long surgery and
this is of course suboptimal for a
patient who's 10 years old and who has
to undergo a 12-hour operation so I was
like this is 2017 or 2015 whatever year
it was 2012 and we cannot do this we
cannot have this operation less this
long so I thought what if somebody made
a cookie cutter that could allow us to
do this for you like cookies is that why
you went to the Galapagos okay so like
the Cookie Monster see we never really
give cookies any benefit because we
always blame diabetes and cooking and
all these issues but look cookies can't
save the world and clearly they were a
motivating factor here so absolutely
just like playing with play-doh exactly
there was really a humanitarian mission
and purpose behind it as in the u.s.
it's easy to perform in such operation
with these incredibly talented surgeons
and with the resources that we have but
there are resources poor countries that
cannot have either access to Plastic
Surgeons with that training or have the
economical potential to undergo the
surgery sure so we thought if we make
this cookie cutter we could actually go
to these countries and not only as a
company donate this this device to those
hospitals but also bring our own set of
physicians and train them to perform the
operation without basically giving them
a fish but basically teaching them how
to fish one of my students who was
actually writing papers with me and who
was very interested in plastic surgery
who holds a biomedical engineering
degree from MIT told me one day like
that impressive not impressive at all
too bad he couldn't be here today I said
so basically he was like do you have any
ideas that we can actually bring to
fruition because he had like a month off
and I and I thought you know what in
Italy I thought of this cookie cutter we
need to really bring it to life and we
designed it together and we we start our
Kickstarter campaign which is actually
how we got in touch with you looking for
funds today is a great day because
today's the first day that I actually
see your device yes right automatically
device that can change so many people's
lives and we have the device right here
with us this beautiful very beautiful
project not only is it functional but it
looks great so that whole aspect is
there from a plastic surgery standpoint
so tell us a little bit about absolutely
so this is arisin and was mostly funded
through our Kickstarter campaign as well
as the limitless tomorrow's funds that
you graciously awarded us so it's
basically modular components you have a
top cassette that can that is basically
customizable and then this would be
anchored there you go super easy and
then you would remove the base cassette
you would select the cassette that has
sizes here if you don't see right so
this is a small ear which is a 48
millimeters for example I have small
ears and this gives basically an idea of
where the college should sit in order to
be stamped appropriately with the with a
blade you would just press
and they will ensue boom whether you
raise it you have something that you can
suture together with wires now how much
time does a process like this save from
the actual sculpting because there are
surgeons in the world I can do it
relatively quickly but there you could
probably count them on one hand right I
was lucky enough to actually go to
doctor nagata's clinic in Japan he is
the Guru of your construction one of the
surgeons who advanced the field sure so
currently the gold standard of
reconstruction is this technique which
is what this allows to do super quick so
negara can do this operation in about
four or five hours most surgeons take up
to 12 hours and as you have mentioned
before one minute in the or cost
eighty-two dollars well so if you
consider twelve hours of an operation of
this kind the cost would be about forty
to forty-five thousand dollars you guys
do the math so this would allow to carve
everything at a very precise level in a
matter of seconds and then they're
assembling and then the actual
attachment the attachment to a
subcutaneous pocket would take probably
like an hour or two and now the other
techniques that exist what's the
difference between those and so there is
another technique that uses a polymer
and a synthetic ear framework and not
human
it's not human it out of different
compounds that are not found within
correct it's basically biocompatible
plastic okay and you basically put it
underneath the skin flaps and you create
an ear unfortunately the results are not
always optimal and not in everyone's
hands are optimal and at the same time
it's still a foreign body so it can give
a lot of inflammation it can give
infections you can stick out and we call
that extrusion and when they sticks out
usually the whole area gets infected you
can go back to square one or even to a
worse scenario has there ever been
thought about using donor application
cartilage or is that or maybe even
animal cartilage you know pick cartilage
is used well certainly in medical stuff
absolutely so a pay
cartilage or cadaveric cartilage have a
hurdle which is the fact that pick
cartilage is a xeno transplant so he's a
transplant between three different
species and for that reason it will be
rejected
okay so you cannot be used so you would
resorb and actually create an probably
an infection as well at the same time
cadaveric cartilage which we use
actually during this kind of
reconstruction has been irradiated and
the cells are not going to do not
quality they well they're not going to
give an immunological response so
they're not going to be attacked by your
own body so it is used sometimes the
resource a lot and often we do not get
enough of that in big pieces to really
make the ear so we really need to get
the patient's own ribs got it what's the
next step how we're gonna see this in
real-world application how long does
that take so as you can imagine it takes
a long time because first is gonna you
will need to be tested by skilled
surgeons in a very controlled fashion
which is what we plan on doing my
institution it could be as quick as one
or two years I could take way longer it
really all depends on the funding that
we were able to of course be able to
secure and then of course the reach that
we can get through you and in general in
your institution and you guys yeah so
people want to learn more about the rise
in device they want to maybe even donate
and help you achieve even more
spectacular results with the device what
do they do where do they go so they can
donate definitely to our company we are
setting up a non-for-profit branch that
will allow us to finance both the device
and the humanitarian mission portion of
it we want to give a huge thank you for
having you here today thank you for
having me and all the amazing work that
you're doing and we wish you the best of
luck for myself and I'm sure everyone
watching at home thank you very much
[Music]